si escuchan muchas noticias relacionadas
con los fondos de cobertura en tonos de
sospecha o negativos lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es analizar los aspectos a
observar para saber si un fondo de
cobertura o cualquier institución
financiera es buena o mala algunas de
las quejas que hay sobre los fondos de
cobertura es por el porcentaje de la
comisión por rendimiento se quedan con
un 20 por ciento de las ganancias si por
alguna razón el fondo fallara y quedar
en ceros el gerente del fondo no tendría
pérdidas del 20% por eso muchas personas
dicen que los administradores o gerentes
de los fondos toman muchos riesgos o
riesgos desproporcionados y esto es
cierto hasta cierto punto pero otra cosa
que es cierta de los fondos de cobertura
es que el dueño de la empresa gerencial
también tiene parte de su pellejo en
riesgo como en el ejemplo que les puse
del fondo de capital de pitt 1
la empresa gerencia aportó el 10% del
fondo lo más importante además de esto
es el porcentaje del valor neto total de
pitt
se encuentra en este fondo y muchos
gerentes ponen una cantidad
significativa de su valor neto en el
fondo así que aunque obtenga el 20 por
ciento de las ganancias residía
terriblemente mal si el fondo perdiera
particularmente al gerente ese es el
objetivo de la sociedad limitada en
comparación de los fondos mutualistas ya
habíamos mencionado que los socios
limitados de los fondos de cobertura
tienen que ser sofisticados tienen que
ser inversionistas acreditados deben
tener un valor neto y deben demostrar
que conocen ese tipo de instrumentos así
que está en el mejor interés de los
mismos socios limitados el asegurarse
que invierten en un fondo confiable que
pitt sea una persona confiable que
también tenga inversión en su propio
fondo y una parte sustancial de su
propio valor neto también les debe
interesar que [ __ ] tenga una buena
reputación y los inversionistas deben
elegir su nivel de confianza con
respecto a que transparente es el fondo
de pitt ya que muchos fondos de
cobertura no le informan a sus
inversionistas sobre lo que hacen y esto
podría ser malo
que podrían viajar a las vegas y apostar
el dinero del fondo y es por eso que la
reputación del gerente importa mucho
aunque el secreto también podría ser
bueno para el fondo ya que a veces si
todos conocen lo que pasa dentro del
fondo y esa información sale las otras
personas que son competidoras de dicho
fondo podrían tratar de adelantarse a
las estrategias de este fondo hay
ventajas y desventajas de que haya
secreto pero el riesgo siempre está
presente la idea de que hay mucho
porcentaje de las ganancias y muy poco
del porcentaje de las pérdidas no es
exclusivo de los fondos de cobertura de
hecho esto también se aplica a todos los
ejecutivos corporativos que
probablemente no tienen su pellejo en
riesgo ya hemos escuchado sobre los
paracaídas de oro y enormes bonos que
reciben y si algo sale terriblemente mal
y los despiden aún así tendrán
paracaídas de oro lo que no sucede con
los gerentes de los fondos de cobertura
así que esta idea no es exclusiva de
estos fondos otra de las nociones que
las personas tienen sobre los fondos de
cobertura
idea de que son secretos ya que no están
regulados
el gerente del fondo es quien elige lo
que se hace con el dinero o cómo se
invierte este y aquí escribo secreto con
asterisco porque para que los
inversionistas se decidan a dar su
dinero aquí se les tiene que decir algo
de lo que se va a hacer con él y eso
depende del gerente del fondo sin
embargo en la parte del secreto
combinado con el hecho de que pueden
invertir en negocios más exóticos aunque
no todos lo hacen los fondos de
cobertura aún cuando tienen esa
estructura del 2% de comisión gerencial
y el 20 por ciento de comisión por
desempeño las inversiones que se hacen
lucen muy similares a las de los fondos
mutualistas e incluso podrían ser más
conservadores que éstas así que no
siempre son las arriesgadas las
inversiones en un fondo de cobertura
aunque bueno algunas veces sí lo son y
es por eso que con los secretos y la
posibilidad de invertir en cosas locas
pues da la impresión de que no son muy
confiables mi opinión particular es que
los fondos de cobertura son más pequeños
en relación con otros fondos los bienes
que controlan son más
pequeños y si estos bienes son más
pequeños con derivados sofisticados por
ejemplo con 100 millones se puede
controlar más de 100 millones de bienes
nacionales pero si los bienes nacionales
controlados por el fondo de cobertura
son relativamente pequeños entonces la
discreción y las estrategias de
inversión son las que podrían poner en
riesgo a los inversionistas por lo que
es el trabajo de estas personas y no la
sociedad como un todo lo que peligra el
momento en el que están en riesgo estos
fondos de cobertura el ejemplo más obvio
de esto es la gerencia de capital a
largo plazo o glp de la cual haré su
respectiva serie de vídeos cuando hay
una gerencia de capital a largo plazo
que podría controlar muchos de los
fondos nacionales y aquí hablamos de
cientos de miles de millones o incluso
billones de dólares de manera que este
fondo se vuelve demasiado grande para
caer
y creo que ustedes sabrán debido a la
reciente crisis financiera que esto no
solo le ocurre a los fondos de cobertura
en general cuando cualquier organización
financiera comienza a tener el control
de billones o cientos de miles de
millones de dólares en el país no va a
ser algo bueno esto no es bueno ya que
si algo es demasiado grande para caer'
la gente no lo dejará caer y esto va en
contra de la filosofía del capitalismo
cuando alguien hace las cosas bien le va
bien y cuando alguien hace las cosas mal
se le deja caer quiero hacer énfasis en
que esta es gc lp no es único de los
fondos de cobertura la corporación
una de las más conocidas en la reciente
crisis financiera estaban seguros que
eran demasiado grandes para caer' y
también hubo varios bancos demasiado
grandes para caer el mensaje aquí es que
los fondos de cobertura pueden ser
buenos o malos pero lo que tienen de
diferencia única con respecto a los
fondos mutualistas es que tienden a ser
un poco más privados deben tener
inversionistas más sofisticados y lo que
hacen con el dinero puede ser lo mismo
que hacen los fondos mutualistas
e incluso ser más conservadores y pueden
usar herramientas sofisticadas para
correr menos riesgos pero cualquiera de
estas organizaciones financieras pueden
volverse malos cuando crecen tanto que
cuando les va mal no solo se afectan a
ellos sino también a toda la sociedad